welcome to this video against malecon
from finland yeah that's a really bad
score one out of four mm-hmm
yeah you have those kind of opponents
where you don't fare well I think he
played some fairly wacky games against
me I have this vague memory or something
okay we're playing a Dutch defense iam
just trying to try to be quick about it
adds a kind of a weird setup but like
sometimes can get away with rehab things
in the Dutch sea going to go for a night
before maybe but not before that
f1 is going there
can't start with that more is this a
good idea I don't know or back to our
form
yeah maybe let's let's do this one
secure my bishop down keep keep my
options open
okay I'm going to retreat now 495
you're not taking really okay
allowing me to take on c6 would have
been somewhat strange decision okay
Jack I see here maybe provoke some
weakness there c6 Queen b3 there's an
idea okay yeah also I have Queen b3 and
rook b8 I can take a 6 that was one idea
his old said I was rather weird here
with rook e8 and so on but well as
mentioned I think I've played him before
and that was also kind of a strange game
do I want to okay he can't go be fire to
prevent c4 but that looks really
weakening maybe possible though no not
clear how bad this is
yeah okay let's push this back and see
that if I get my knight is somehow
connected with the rest of this game
Knight to c4 us maybe an idea
hmm Kuki night will come to see form now
f3 wasn't a good news
now that wasn't a good movement okay not
not exactly a move that I love to play
but I see no no real way to keep it on
the board I was thinking more details
but I know here
has a somewhat different idea about
about strategy than I have I think
details and Bishop g5 look more looked
more natural to me now he has this
somewhat strange Bishop there
yeah I can go to g3 I can check g5 let's
go to g3 can I open the be found I know
it opens the diagonal but then I think I
want to be found for some kind of some
kind of play there before I would be one
I don't know it's tricky to play this
kind of this kind of completely wacky
position with a little time complained
and it's not leading to much I can do
that check check no I have no real a
check there and taking taking f5 if it's
not not leading to anything I guess and
she will be he will play h3 them
probably
okay at least least the rocks off you
still has a weird bishop on g8 off - off
to e5 if possible would be nice
yeah we can go Bishop d6 somehow
and again it's not it's not super clear
maybe queen f2 to g3 is the way to go
then probably anyway I want I want to
try to get to his Bishop there that
should be nice now come on
oh it's Bishop h5 working like miracle
miracle move no um 97 not on Queen g7 I
mean time warning maybe he goes I did I
did we maybe this is good if you trade
the Queen's I came here I can actually
invade I think I'm coming the knight
will cover my king check
I hope that is the right judgment
judgment check check
check
25 now I have no time
check awkward did you take the a porn
that I hate that I hate that he's
getting away with this
unbelievable black for effects on talent
one on time I actually didn't see that
ah yeah well I I don't know I never even
saw that my I've had out of time I was
just staring in disbelief that I'm
managed to screw this game up check I
mean here there must be some kind of
will yeah don't tell me there's no win
stockfish is saying 0.1 it's known in
this position why why is that because
that cannot be true and now it gets a
bit higher jacket there is no now
quicking of to happy for white at least
oh wow or the game and this this should
be like a complete win and somehow it
wasn't I don't know why
it's remarkable how resilient this
position is yeah as ugly as it looks and
it's full of holes this is bad bishop
there and it's not like a complete win
amazing it's really amazing
Chandler and computer finds nothing here
really and around here I really don't
know how to assess this it's just so
wacky maybe this is why a place like
that I don't do it too well in wacky
positions
I hear d5 is winning okay
yeah those kind of things can be can be
miss Jerry why is it winning because he
I have Queen a4 check check King here
rook e1 they all care this kind of
random tactic it's not so check not so
easy to care to see from him again d5 is
a move but I thought about breakthroughs
but I didn't really see anything here
but life was of course quite threatening
him understandably channel rather tricky
but the check I have always have native
won him now can always play them the
safe move thinking that at some point
the structure should count but so you
will check but I didn't know check need
really noticed that I'm sure that I
mentioned on time so I didn't play on
time or anything here I was just sharing
their disbelief that I'm not winning
somehow and yeah yeah I really did not
did not spot that heap warnings if I go
in five this is also a different story
because that takes him much longer to
get to the pawn and see for hangs so
this might still be something their
computer actually likes white quite a
lot but I'm not totally sure them
like this this fire fatigues check it
would be kind of strange of this isn't a
draw right I think that's probably going
to enter the draw yeah what do we add
game yeah this this guy is playing
somewhat weird chess I mean I'm not
saying bad it's just it just something
that's completely beyond my my kind of
scope yeah what we understand any of
those moves so well thanks for watching